you're studying so hard and after like a
four hour game and you actually are on
the opposite end and you win you feel
like such a huge rush of dopamine and
serotonin and you're like on a high from
the wind so there's also plus sides or
you can turn this around but yeah like
alex said like losing after preparing
for something and fighting on hours and
hours is the worst feeling in the world
did you ever get anything like that with
martial arts
yeah so you know wrestling i wrestled
all through high school in middle school
definitely so it's an individual sport i
did a lot of individual sport tennis
those kinds of things
but i think even with wrestling and
tennis you're still on a team right you
can still like there's still a
camaraderie there i feel like with chess
especially you go on your own with the
tournaments
like it you really are alone but i i
mean i always personally just had us
like a very self-critical mind in
general i would not that's one of the
reasons i decided not to play chess
because i think when i was really young
i met
somebody uh
who was able to play blindfold chess
they were teaching me they were laying
there on the couch trash drinking and
smoking
yeah exactly um there are now a faculty
somewhere in the united states i forget
where but
he um
making jokes talking to others and he
would move the pieces
like he you yell across the room
and i remember
thinking that
if a person is able to do that
then that kind of world you can live in
inside your mind that becomes the chess
board to me that meant like the chess
board is not just out here it could be
in here and you could do these beautif
you can create these beautiful patterns
in your mind
i thought like
i
had such a strong pull towards that
or where i had to decide either i'm
gonna dedicate everything to this
or not
uh you can't do half-assed and then i
that's when i decided
um to walk away from it because i had so
much other beautiful things in my life i
loved mathematics i loved just
everything was beautiful to me i thought
chess
would pull me all in
and
there was nothing like it i think in my
whole life since then i think it's such
a dangerous addiction
it's such a beautiful addiction but it's
a dangerous one depending on what your
mind is like it reminds me of something
i thought of
before i stopped competing as much and
i'd look at people and think
imagine being
so intelligent that you could become a
grand master and yet only spending the
rest of your life being a grandmaster
because it's one of those things where
it does require a lot of mental power
but by doing chess you're not going to
be able to explore other subjects deeply
yeah and not in a way that is is bad
necessarily more in admiration and
wondering what else could have been
because i've just seen people get to
these levels of obsession where it's all
they want to do and they're grandmasters
but they're not even top players so
they're never going to make a living out
of it they'll make like maybe 30 40k
your max they can't even focus on their
competitive chess because they have to
supplement it by you know teaching and
doing things they don't like and it's
just because of how strong of an
obsession it can be because it truly is
very intellectually rewarding um and i
think that's what people are addicted to
and the self-improvement but you can get
that from a lot of other things as well
well i think for me what i was inspired
by that stuck with me is that
a human being could be
so good
at
one thing
right to me that person on the college
drinking so on i
i assumed he was the best chess player
in the world
like that to be able to play inside your
head right
uh
it just
felt like a feat that's incredible and
so i
fell in love with the idea that i hope
to be something like that in my life at
something it would be pretty cool to be
really good at one thing and like life
in some sense is a search for the things
that you could be that good at i didn't
even think about like how much money
does it make or any of that
is can i fall in love with something
and make it a life pursuit where i can
be damn good at it and the being damn
good at it
is the source of enjoyment not
not like um
not to win because you want to win a
tournament or win because
uh
like you just want to be better somebody
else no it's for the beauty of the game
itself or the beauty of the activity
itself and then you realize that that's
one of the compelling things about chess
it is a game with rules and you can win
if you want to be really damn good in
some aspect of life like that
it's it's it's harder
it's a harder and weirder pursuit don't
you feel like you kind of did that with
computer science or ai related things
like getting that level of
damn good that's one of the cool things
about
ai and
robotics or intellectual pursuits or
scientific pursuits is you can spend
until you're 80 doing it so i'm in the
early days of that one of the thing
reasons i came to texas
one of the reasons
i didn't want to pursue an academic
career at mit
is i want to build
a company
and so that i'm in the early days of
that
ai company and so it's an open world to
see if i'm actually going to be good at
it but the thing that's
there
that i've been cognizant of my whole
life is that i have a passion for it
something within me
draws me to that thing and you have to
listen to that to that voice so with
chess
you're [ __ ] unless you like early on
are really training really hard
i think life is more forgiving
you can be you can be world class at a
thing after
after making a lot of mistakes
and after spending the first
few decades of your life doing something
completely different in chess it's like
um it's like an olympic sport like
there's no
perfection is a requirement it's a
necessity
what do you think is that pursuit for
you
like why did you decide to stream
what what drew you i like these
questions that were really getting deep
yeah this is like a therapy session i
mean what um isn't it terrifying to be
in front of a camera
well it's terrifying to be in front of
five cameras instead of corrections six
six okay more terrifying for me oh yeah
try to remember
if i actually turn them all i'm like i
mentioned to you off mike i'm still
suffering from a bit of ptsd after
uh screwing up a recording of magnus i i
uh he had to console me
because
that was the thing is i
felt okay you want to you want to build
robots
if you can't get a camera to even run
correctly
how are you going to do anything else in
life oh no don't let it spiral
it was spiraling hard yeah and i was
just laying there and just just feeling
sorry for myself but i think that
feeling by the way
and a small tangent is really useful
like yeah i feel like a lot of growing
happens when you feel shitty as long
as long as you can get out of it like
don't let it spiral like indefinitely
but just feeling really really shitty
about everything in my life like i was
having an existential crisis like how i
how will i be able to do anything at all
like this you're a giant failure all
those kinds of negative voices
um but i think i made some good
decisions in the in the week after that
do you think you couldn't have made
those decisions if you were less hard on
yourself
me personally
no i'm too lazy
okay so you really need to be angry at
yourself enough to go and do what yeah
it's not even angry it's just upset of
being self-critical like
also for me personally because i don't
have
proclivities for depression
i
have a lot more uh room to feel
extremely shitty about myself
so
if you if you're somebody that can get
stuck in that place like clinically
depressed you have to be really really
careful you have to notice the triggers
you don't want to get into that place
but for me
just looking empirically feeling shitty
has always been
productive
like it makes me long-term happier
ultimately it makes me more grateful to
be alive it helps me grow all those
kinds of things so i kind of
embrace it otherwise i feel like i will
never do anything i have to feel shitty
but that's not a thing
i prescribe to others there's a there's
a famous professor at mit his name is
marvin minsky
and uh when he was giving advice about
like to the students
he said the secret to my success was
that i always hated everything
uh i did in in the past
so always sort of being self-critical
about everything you've accomplished
never really take a moment of gratitude
and i think for a lot of people that
hear that that's not good you should be
you should like take a pause and be
grateful but it really worked for him so
you know it's a choice you have to make
it reminds me of the quote be happy but
never satisfied
where
you can have a positive spin
and still want to improve yourself
you